new homes have had the option of
building with solar power for a long
time in the United States and the cost
of doing so has come down over time but
California is going to make solar power
a standard requirement on all new homes
built in their state and the day after
tomorrow the California Energy
Commission will be voting on new energy
standards for new homes and they're
expected to mandate solar panels on
homes built starting in 2020 so this all
sounds great
except that there are two camps that
oppose this both on the left and on the
right so you've got the right wing
anti-regulation types who say they just
don't want more regulation and the
government telling people how they have
to build homes of course there's always
been regulation or at least for a long
time on new homes whether it's
insulation standards or heating
efficiency standards whatever this is
just the evolution of those standards I
don't think that's a very good argument
but there are also people sort of on the
Left who wanted a net zero requirement
they wanted Net Zero to be the standard
meaning that the house has to produce
more solar power than it uses not hugely
realistic because right now our ability
to store solar energy is pretty limited
so at night when the Sun is down homes
even with normal solar installations
need to pull electricity from the grid
so the decision was made that's a little
too much right now let's mandate some
solar of course there will be some
exceptions and that's almost always the
case here and the important thing to
remember is yeah even if really rich
people building mansions are going to
potentially be able to get exceptions or
some large commercial office buildings
or I'm sorry not commercial leased
buildings least residential buildings
will be able to get exemptions overall
this is a move in the right direction
and like with any market that has new
regulation people will be able to get
around it some people will but the big
picture is a really really good one and
I think that there's another interesting
element here that people often like to
point out which is ok fine you put the
solar panels on and the energy is so is
solar but you need fossil fuels to make
the solar panels and you've got all
these solar installers driving around
burning gasoline even if they have
electric cars that they're driving
the electricity comes from fossil fuels
we've dealt with that argument many
times before that needs to be figured
out and it eventually will be but in the
short term let's at least make the move
to solar power and then we'll continue
to work on reducing the carbon footprint
and the fossil fuel foot footprint of
the creation and installation of the
solar panels like that that's one of
those examples where people say well
there's still fossil fuels in the system
for doing solar panel installation yes
there is but you're taking a step up the
chain towards renewability and
sustainability we that argument was made
on the show ten years ago it made no
sense then and it makes no sense now
the real concern I have is that real
estate prices are so out of control in
California especially in the area in and
around San Francisco Los Angeles as well
that anything you do that will initially
make it more expensive to build a house
is going to make real estate even more
expensive and I don't actually have the
answer to that even though in the long
term having solar saves you money on
heating anything that's gonna push
prices up in California even further is
something I would be very very concerned
about and I've not yet heard a good
explanation as to why I shouldn't worry
about that if you have an answer let me
know we've got a great bonus show for
you today I don't have time to tell you
what's on it I don't have time to play a
voicemail for you but the bonus show
will be great today and I hope you'll
join me then today's program made
possible in part by zip recruiter every
business needs great people and they
also need a better way to find them and
there's a better option than posting
your job online and hoping or praying if
that's your thing for the right people
to see your ad zip recruiter knew there
was a smarter way so they built a
platform that finds the right job
candidates for you so the way it works
is once a zip recruiter learns what
you're looking for and you post your job
they will identify people in their
system with the right experience and
invite them to apply for your job and
these invitations have really
revolutionized how people find their
next hires and in fact 80% of employers
who post a job on zip recruiter and get
a quality candidate through the site in
the first 24 hours and zip recruiter
does not stop
they will also spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you'll never
miss the great matches that are there
the right candidates are out there and
zip recruiter is how you find them
businesses of all sizes trust zip
recruiter for hiring needs and my
viewers and listeners can try zip
recruiter for free that's right for free
if you go to zip recruiter comm slash
Pakman that is zip recruiter comm slash
PA KMA and one more time zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman